[Music]
hi steve
hi
how is it hanging out for like 20
minutes but it's like
still awkward right um
how does it feel to be back in front of
everyone you're not on zoom anymore
yeah it feels nice you know we had a
game last night in portland and and it
was first
time really that we felt a full full
house
with fans
we had
last year at the end of the season we
had some fans back in the building but
not a full house and last night you
could just feel the energy it was like
everybody was
so excited just to have some semblance
of normalcy so
this feels good too it's good to be back
with with people yeah hopefully we
recreate that energy here tonight um
during this talk uh before we dive into
the interview
i wanted to share
if you do want to show us the bottom
half of your face you have two options
stay hydrated so lots of water okay or
option two we've been told is if this
was a performance you can actually
remove your mass if you want to shoot
some three-pointers for us
let us know so i could actually remove
this if i perform absolutely if you
shoot your career percentage tonight
then you can opt to remove that yeah
anyway
um let's dive in in all seriousness
so the mass stays or goes which one um
i don't see a ball i don't see yeah do
we have a basketball in the crowd over
here somewhere
i could juggle maybe a judge or maybe
any other performance would also do i
don't think i really know how to do
anything else actually
we don't want you to put us to shame to
be honest i think that's the real reason
we don't have a bastard wall here
um but thank you for being here at the
gsb we're super excited um we think we
have a lot to learn from you
uh not just steve kerr the player the
general manager the head coach
but also the podcast host the social
commentator
so you want to dive in
let's perhaps start with leadership how
would you describe your style of
leadership in your own words
i think
i lead my team a little bit like i
raised my
children
my wife and i
did that together and and we always
sort of gave them a lot of rope but um
they kind of knew they they
they were responsible for that freedom
and so i believe in the same kind of
leadership with the team you can tell by
the way we play we
you know we're pretty fast paced we're
risky we shoot a lot of
crazy shots especially steph and clay
but i believe
that the the freedom that they have
makes them play more instinctively
and that ultimately when you're coaching
a basketball team the players it's their
team
and so you you have to
give them the team but give give them
the blueprint for
how it's all going to work and once
once the
culture is set and the idea is set about
you know what we're trying to accomplish
you kind of let them go and then you
just rein them in when you feel like you
need to rein them in so
i would i would say that's
that's kind of my style that's your
style i hurt freedom i heard rest but i
also hurt children
and i wanna i wanna touch on that
where does that come from and i'm and
i'm curious if this is from your own
time as a child and you're upbringing
where does that style you just described
to us
where did you find that
probably my own parents
i was kind of a
strange kid to be honest with you i was
um
super competitive um at a very young age
to the point where it was it was it was
actually kind of embarrassing for the
family
and i i say that only half jokingly but
give us an example what was the
embarrassing part
so like when you have a family easter
egg hunt and
and i don't find the the big pro you
know the golden egg
and throw a complete tantrum at the age
of five because i didn't find the golden
egg that's kind of embarrassing for the
parents
we felt that competitive at the gsb but
yeah yeah
so that's but that was kind of for
whatever reason that was the way i was
wired and and
it carried over to sports and um
so i i think my parents were really
interesting they gave me a lot of rope
and they knew they somehow they knew
like when they'd go to my
baseball games by by the way back then
parents didn't go to every single game
you know they just like if it was a
thursday there's no way mom and dad were
going you know i was like they might go
on saturday it was a little different
back then hi tara
so
sometimes i'd throw a complete
fit
you know if i
got out or you know in baseball or you
know missed a bunch of shots but
whatever i would just
throw a complete tantrum and
my parents didn't really say anything
until later like you know at dinner time
they so they somehow they
instinctively knew
just wait until i had cooled off a
little bit right and
and i think it was pretty powerful
because by that time you
by the time you cool off it's a lot
easier to see what you've actually done
right so i had to learn how to kind of
tame that
competitiveness and channel in the right
direction and i think my parents really
helped me do that and so
i think that
probably is in some way maybe
subconsciously um
kind of the way i i i guide my own team
right
i want to touch more um on your
upbringing and your parents you were
born in beirut
your father malcolm was also born in
beerud i there's a lot of movement
between lebanon and egypt other
mediterranean countries and then los
angeles was your father was a professor
not many
players or gm's or head coaches have
that experience at that age or that
point of their career
how did that exposure that international
culture
impact you with kind of shape not just a
leadership style but your world view uh
moving forward
yeah it was probably the
the best education i received as as a
child growing up was living overseas you
know we lived in i was born in beirut as
you mentioned i've lived in
cairo egypt for about three years when
my dad was a visiting professor at the
american university there and
we spent time in france and tunisia and
and so i had a really good experience in
terms of just seeing
other cultures and living in other
cultures um
seeing
especially in cairo
you know abject poverty and seeing
how wonderful the people were
and and yet how little so many of them
had
and when you're 10 12 years old that's
really powerful especially coming from
los angeles where we were you know my
dad was a professor at ucla and we spent
a lot of time on campus and it's kind of
this idyllic um scene just like here in
stanford and
so the contrast and it's great
perspective for a young
person to to feel that at a young age
and then i think you you know naturally
sort of he builds some empathy but
perspective and and i try to introduce
perspective with our team as often as i
can that's something greg popovich was
amazing with
in san antonio and
i think it's really crucial just
for all of our players to understand how
lucky we are to
compete and play basketball for a living
and and be able to
come into the gym every day and be
together and
it's so much fun and and you know most
of the world is
trying to get by so we're really
incredibly blessed yeah
are there specific stories
from that childhood the time in cairo
seeing the abject poverty that come to
mind that i've started with you that you
perhaps have shared with
players or colleagues or your staff that
you that you've held on to
there's a
an area in cairo called the city of the
dead and it's um
when i was there this was in you know
the early
late 70s early 80s
there were like a million people who
lived
basically in a cemetery underneath um
these uh
cemetery area
obviously a pretty brutal
you know nickname for for the the place
but i remember driving by it and asking
you know why is it called the city of
the den well it's you know there's
this is a burial ground and a lot of
people are you know
living here because this is the only
space they have and it's like
how do you how do you reconcile that
with you know life in
pacific palisades going to ucla
basketball games and thinking you know
the world was a pretty easy place to be
and so
i think that all that all really stuck
with me forever
yeah
thanks for sharing that i feel like the
way you shared that and that emotion
it's it's still very
alive with you and you carry that on
you mentioned greg popovich as well um
one of you know in my opinion at least
personally i'm sure you'll agree the the
best leaders out there and not just
coach but leader in the nba
you've worked with him you've also
worked with phil jackson at the bulls
when you talk about leadership styles
anything you found from either of those
two that you that you've hunted on and
you would like to embody yourself
with your team oh yeah i mean
almost everything that i do is
a reflection of
either phil or pop or loud olsen
but the thing that i
really learned as i went is that if
you're not authentic to yourself your
players are going to feel that right
away so while the influence is there
from all of those guys and
definitely a lot of the basketball drill
work and the philosophy comes from the
people i learned
uh
you know playing under it still has to
be my
my own values that i share with the team
every day because that's going to be
authentic and they'll feel that
authenticity um
you know they i i was really dealt an
amazing hand when i got here because um
most first-time
coaches
take over bad teams you know and we
already had a good team
but the the
opportunity to coach steph curry and
i i could i could go on
with a number of players in this
conversation but steph in particular
because i think we share
two really
crucial values that define our whole
team
and that is joy and competitiveness
steph is a
just a vicious competitor but you
wouldn't know it
um
because he of the way he looks and the
joy that he plays with
um
but we see we see the world in a similar
way you know we've we understand the
power of
of competing for something but the power
of joy within that and and so finding
that balance every day is kind of the
key to to what makes our team tick but
to be able to coach someone who shares
your values like that is
just an incredible
asset for a coach for a leader
and to have somebody like steph who's
so strong
in terms of his own leadership
it's
i've been just incredibly blessed right
i wanna you touched on steph and i want
to maybe dive deeper into a part of
leadership
and that's people management
like a lot of us here at the gsb
we'll
graduate enter jobs where we perhaps
have to manage our direct reports and
you know those beneath us in the org
chart as well as upwards towards our
managers our bosses and so on
you've had a similar experience you have
to manage
gm president operations owners as well
as your own staff players and so on
how do you like what framework do you
use so what's your mental model when you
think about you know leveraging
authority both upwards downwards and you
know
sideways i think uh i think just being
aware of everybody's challenges and and
and trying to
remind yourself on a daily basis
that every single person in the
organization
has
challenges vulnerabilities
strengths weaknesses
we're all trying for the same thing but
it's very natural for there to be
blame you know the
the
front office might sign a player and it
doesn't turn out you know maybe
maybe they draft a player and they don't
think we're developing the player well
or maybe our coaches are thinking well
we should have drafted somebody like all
that stuff there's there's
the potential for that every single day
just like in
any business right there's so many
people when you get so many people
involved
there's there's potential conflict so i
just try to think of and obviously
depending on what's going on with the
team
i just try to think each day of you know
who do i need to check in with and
maybe it's just a phone call or an email
but but maintaining those lines of
communication
constantly is you know like you said
managing in every direction it's um it's
really crucial yeah and it's a big part
of the job right you mentioned
communication there and i want to maybe
touch on that a little bit more
um this is specifically around creating
a culture
that is both diverse and inclusive so we
hear that a lot i want to focus more on
the inclusive part which is not just
having a diverse set of individuals on
the team but making them feel like they
belong they have a voice there is open
communication regardless of where they
are in the ort chart
i think back it was in
june 2015
nba finals game four
you started andre de dalla for the first
time and i believe there was a watch
journal article about this that a 28
year old video assistant who was fairly
junior on your staff
came up with an analysis
to prompt you to do that
you tell us more about kind of what that
story was and there was a 3am text
message also involved in there somewhere
um what what what enabled a junior staff
member to have an impact which went on
to make andre the finals mvp yeah well
it's one of the one of the things i
really learned from from pop playing in
san antonio he used to say all the time
anybody can
can have a good idea it doesn't matter
where it comes from
let's explore everything and if
you know if one of you has a thought
bring it up and he would say the same
thing to all the coaches and so it was
very inclusive there and i and i thought
that was really powerful and i wanted to
to uh create the same sort of culture
here and so that was the way we operated
we sort of embraced
all ideas i encouraged everybody all the
coaches to talk during during meetings
and if they had something to say to try
to get get it out of them and
same thing in the in the huddles you
know take a timeout and
you know we might see something as a
coaching staff and the players might
feel differently and um so you know
sometimes i'll say in the timeout hey
i'm thinking we should do this you know
what do you guys think
and usually it's draymond who says no we
should do something different
and
uh but draymond's really smart and he's
the one who's out there and so you know
a lot of times like all right you know
if you guys feel strongly about that
let's do that
so i think um
but to do that you have to you have to
be comfortable in your own skin you have
to to embrace a really
i think a really crucial
aspect of leadership which is that
you actually
will come across stronger
to the people you're leading
if you show
that you don't have all the answers
right i think sometimes leaders feel
like oh my gosh i've gotta gotta have
all the answers
otherwise they're not gonna respect me i
think it's sort of the opposite as long
as
long as they know you're putting in the
work and that you know what you're
talking about because what we're doing
is is more art than science you know
this is it's a basketball game so
there's no
perfect answer for anything
so if you can you know be collaborative
and sometimes allow the players to make
a decision or the video coordinator or
um
there shouldn't be any hesitation to do
that
as long as you don't blame that person
if it doesn't work you know you gotta
you gotta own
own the decision afterwards and whatever
it is um and give credit if credit is
due and
but but if you just do that
and it and it comes naturally and you
feel comfortable with that it's a really
powerful force um because then the
players take ownership
um but doing that while maintaining your
um
your sense of
you know you're the person in charge
ultimately is kind of the balance that
we're all looking for yeah yeah i see a
lot of similarities with what you said
earlier about leadership is giving that
freedom that rope
allowing them to feel like they're part
of the process and they have ownership
and then actually being the decision
maker with all the inputs yourself
um
perhaps you know more specifically on
people management
there was a situation i believe back in
november 2018
um
the warriors were playing the clippers
down in l.a
nationally televised game
there was a confrontation on television
between kevin durant and draymond green
two of your superstars
when you had to deal with that situation
that confrontation what learnings from
your past experiences you've mentioned
popovich a couple of times and others
what did you lean on in that moment to
defuse that situation and move on from
that situation which was potentially a
pretty difficult transportation that i
just uttered yeah that one was a tough
one that's uh i had never experienced
anything like that you know where two
players got into it you know in a game
like that so i think that's more
instinct than anything i think as a
leader as a coach
you have to have
kind of non-negotiables you have the
players need to know
what's
what line can be crossed what what line
can't be crossed and um
just felt like that was um
too much and bob myers and i you know
got together and
handled it the way we thought was best
there was no
easy answer and and um
you know we we just tried to do the best
we could with it but it was very very
difficult and
and obviously when you're doing it
you know with the public
staring at you and and knowing
everything that's at stake
it's not an easy position to be in but
um
it's gonna happen you know when you're
in in a leadership position there are
very difficult decisions to make and you
just kind of have to do what you think
is best i think and what's right yeah
yeah and like you said in your career
over many deadheads that was the first
time you had even come across that so
there's always a curveball around the
corner there's always a first time for
any situation
i'm sure you've learned a lot from that
what have you taken away in front of
what's stuck with you
going forward now almost three years on
um how is that incident and dealing with
that net new scenario
changed your
your opinion or style on people
management
well how many people here are going to
tweet about it if i answer it like with
yeah just keep your hands down yeah
this is part of modern life it's really
difficult you know you you
it's it's harder and harder to
um
to live a public life
and
really open up
and and share you know things that that
happen because all of a sudden
you know things come right back around
and so it's it's that that's one that
was very um
very difficult to deal with and
obviously draymond brought it up you
know a couple months back and then it
started all over again and
so you know not my not my favorite uh
topic to discuss so
great can we talk about the
championships yeah
let's talk about that
[Applause]
um just
i'm hopefully another one coming up next
year um in terms of championships but
yeah good um
i want to dive into perhaps decision
making steve
and perhaps i want to go back to a
couple of different scenarios and just
if you could share with us your thought
process or what you were how you came to
those conclusions decisions i think that
would be helpful
the first one was fairly early on in
your time with the warriors it was i
believe there was a potential trade for
kevin love who was just coming off a
stellar year
um with clayton thompson who at the time
was still fairly
uh fairly young in his nba career
i believe you were very much
for clay staying on the team and not
having that trade and of course as they
say the rest is history it has been an
all-star and won three titles
what gave you conviction in that moment
backing and supporting a fairly
unknown or unproven player versus more
of a genuine kind of
proven expert i think that i've been in
the nba now in some capacity for 33
years and and
one of the things i've learned is the
only thing you can be sure of is what's
already been proven on the court
any anytime you you decide to draft
someone or trade for someone
if there's if there's no
history of there's no proof that it's
going to work you're really
taking a chance and so when i became the
warriors coach
uh the the
undisputed truth was that the warriors
had the fourth best defense in the
league with klay thompson
uh
guarding a lot of the point guards that
are out there and it had become a really
pick and roll dominant
game at that by that point now it's even
more so
and you've got clay and steph and from a
basketball standpoint you'd like to be
able to protect steph because he's going
to have to handle the ball so much maybe
put clay on the point guard i mean it
and and it already worked and so
our thinking was we know the warriors
have a great defense already
so if we can improve the offense a
little bit and we think we thought we
could watching the tape we thought you
know a lot of young guys who
with some more seasoning could could
generate you know better shots and
it was all right there whereas
you make a big deal even even if it's
for a great player
you just don't know and so um i think in
those cases you
you're wise to stick with what you do
know if if what you do know is really uh
positive which it was right and where
where did that that uh the training of
that eye and that talent
that conviction come from was it just
seeing clay and stuff in the prior
seasons and the shooter rounds in the
trainings or was there something else in
your experiences that made you believe
that no this is this can come true let's
just give it some more time and actually
see this come through yeah these guys
were pretty young
at the time and and were already
really proficient really
you know steph was already in all-star
clay hadn't been
uh one yet but you could see the
potential
and they were in the playoffs for two
years i mean they they they were great
this is a great team um
you know i i inherited a team that was
that won 50 games that had been the
playoffs the previous couple years
you know the previous staff under mark
jackson had done a great job
establishing a defense the warriors
hadn't had a defense in literally like
30 years
so i mean it was they were the team that
just scored
125 points and usually the other team
scored 127 and that was kind of you know
they were fun to watch but they weren't
going anywhere and
so it was established under mark that
they were going to be become a great
defensive team and the front office did
a really good job putting the pieces
together so
when we got here when my staff got here
it was like this is like this is real we
could you know
we could win the whole thing
and
that's why ultimately uh
you know we we decided to to stay the
course and you know bob it's always
bob's decision and bob was
right with me in terms of
seeing where we could go because we
already had a really good start with the
momentum they had built the previous
couple years right
you mentioned inheriting a good team and
you know it was your first season as a
head coach
at the nba level
and you're you you win their first title
in 40 years i believe the next year you
win 73 regular season games you played
your own team 72 and 10 rattler of the
bulls
a lot of people here also potentially
will it's you know
fairly rapid rises to success almost
overnight success
what if anything changes steve in your
approach to management and just kind of
how you approach your day-to-day at the
job
when you've now drawn from
you know a challenger to now at the top
of that throne and to being that
champion
um
really nothing nothing changed it was i
think the routine of
making sure we're staying
locked in on the the goals that we had
trying to improve on this on the you
know certain keys that we were
uh we thought would take us to the next
step and um
so you know that i think the whole idea
with anything is to is to build um
a a culture
um
a a
kind of an atmosphere that the players
are going to feel
whether you're winning or you're losing
um and and the whole point is to help
the players get better and help them
have the best possible careers they can
have
and so that that's true whether you're
winning championships or you know you
have the worst record in the league it's
still the goal still is the same thing
right so as long as you're generating
that feeling in the gym each day
then you have to be comfortable
with
you know the criticism that's going to
come your way when you're losing
um because that's all that's all part of
it and it's just um part of the
territory right and
how do you you know how do you um
think about managing
perhaps the
the pressure and kind of the magnifying
glass that comes with being at that top
and you said the criticism the blame
you mentioned nothing changes day to day
but as we drove from you know
students into the post graduation you
know real world how do we think about
using
overnight success more tangibly and
thinking about
our next steps in in a way that um
in a way that perhaps we can we were
previously not exposed to and you were
not at that top and not in that
limelight
well i think um first of all i think
life is more difficult now than it's
ever been for all of us you know whether
you're in a position of leadership or if
you're a young person trying to figure
out what you're going to do
um just the nature of life now with
the constant
criticism and judgment that we all have
at our fingertips
that's so difficult to avoid
i know when i played
literally if you wanted to avoid any of
the chatter
you just didn't pick up the morning
paper you know and and i had
an experience in chicago i was trying
out for the bulls and i had a
non-guaranteed contract and i was just
trying to make the team and i was
playing great
and
i decided to pick up the paper one day
thinking you know maybe maybe they're
going to say something nice about me you
know like
pick it up and you can probably guess
where the story's going you know the
writer says well the bulls are going to
make cuts you know the next couple of
days and
steve kerr's probably going to get cut
and so-and-so is probably going to get
cut and i was crushed i was like what is
he talking about i'm playing so well the
next day at practice i was terrible you
know and
so i think about that story sometimes
because
now it's like times a thousand for
everybody right um whether you're trying
out for an nba team or just
trying to get through high school you
know
um
hearing all the judgment and that
criticism and
it's brutal it's it's it's uh so how do
you navigate that how do you
avoid that and um
so finding balance what i what i've
found with our players is the guys who
have the most balance in their life are
the ones who handle all this stuff the
best
work life balance is just crucial you
know
the days of uh
you know
coaches sleeping in their office all
night you know
i mean i i
maybe maybe there are still coaches out
there doing it
probably in the nfl i think that's
that's their you know that's their thing
but it's just insane i think you you
have to have a life you have to have
balance steph is a great example you
know he
he loves life he loves his family he
loves
playing golf he loves
you know being with his kids and you
know being at home for dinner and
every day is a gift to him and so he
takes plenty of heat he takes plenty of
criticism
but he's able to
manage it and navigate it and
and we've had a lot of players who
haven't been able to because their lives
aren't as balanced and so
you know that i guess that's my advice
is to to really seek balance
that work work life relationship
balance the the
and i i find it through
i do a lot of yoga
i like to read i find if i can get into
a good book i'm just kind of in a better
frame of mind each day and
i like to cook you know just just
cooking a meal at home and follow you
know i'm not a
i'm not a chef but if i can find a good
recipe and just go buy the ingredients
and cook and have a game on in the
background and have a beer like that's a
great great day you know that sounds fun
yeah
but that helps me when you know when
people say why the hell doesn't her run
more pick and roll for curry
i can just cook a meal and have a beer
yeah yeah
that must be nice um
but you like you said not all your
players have that balance you know you
mentioned staff and he does that how
what is your role as as a head coach to
is it a nudge in the right direction
is it more explicit than that how
how do you
how do you want to kind of corral as
many of your
of your roster towards that because
you've clearly seen the benefits of that
right
how do you how do you do that yeah it's
a great question i think that's it's one
area where perspective comes in you know
reminding
players
just how fortunate we are
and you can do that
in a variety of ways bringing in guest
speakers um we've had we we're very
lucky because people want to come speak
to the warriors you know and and
so we're we're able to to get a lot of
really interesting people to come in
um and we've had um
we've had like michael lewis came in the
author came in to speak to our team we
had uh
dr dre and jimmy iveen came in and um
you know
gave a presentation on their company on
beats um
we've had
alicia keys and she came in and talked
about her process of of you know writing
a song and writing music and
we've had tommy smith the sprinter from
the 1968 olympics who held up his fist
for uh racial equality right
some incredible guests and
so trying to present something to the
players that is not just
here's how we're guarding pick and roll
it's like this is this is this is life
right and
and then beyond that we try to offer
them as much assistance as we can
in terms of you know we have a
mindfulness coach to help them with uh
meditation with
what we'll do some of that as a team and
then there's you know they'll have
private sessions where we try to help
help people
to to get you know comfortable um
learning how to perform under all this
this uh
judgment we all live under right yeah
and
perhaps this is judgment um
sometimes i see a double standard
for the athletes and the people under
that spotlight versus the rest of us who
are you know more of an office
nine-to-five job
for example a lot of tech companies
during the bay area have unlimited paid
time off um we have unlimited vacation
days and so on
when let's say lebron james does it it's
true it's called load management if he
misses a prime time game people are
upset their television rights and the
sponsors and so on
is that fair is that is that is that a
double standard that we have as a
society between our athletes and
everyone else
yeah but that's part of the deal you
know we try to talk to our team every
year about
what the nba is about you know when you
when you're playing in the nba
you're going to get booed you're going
to get criticized you're going to get
injured you're going to get cut you're
going to get traded
but
if you can navigate it well it's an
amazing job and you're going to make a
lot of money and you're going to have
some great experiences and you get to
play basketball for a living and this is
the trade-off so
you got to understand that right away
i once had i won't name this teammate
but when i was late in my career
i was um i was playing for the blazers
and
one of our rookies on that team would
sit with me and another veteran player a
guy named chris dudley and the coach
maurice cheeks was a coach i think he
wanted this rookie to sit sit with us
and uh so we could share our wisdom we
were both getting ready to retire we'd
been in the league a long time
and this player
first week of the season he he says um
and he's you know exhausted it's been a
month of training camp and games and you
know or maybe maybe a month into the
season
he says um hey guys i have a question so
what's that he says
how much time do we get off for
christmas
chris and i kind of looked at each other
and like
oh boy this is going to be a long
there's a lot to learn
we don't have any time on christmas and
he was you know you could see he was
heartbroken he said we don't get any
time off at all
and uh he's like no you know and it
turned out the coach actually made him
go home for a couple of days he was so
homesick you know and uh
but you kind of have to know what you're
getting into and and the one of the
problems right now with
the league it's not a it's not a problem
it's one it's more of an issue
is that players are coming in at a
younger and younger age
we just drafted two guys in the lottery
who are uh 19 you know they each spent
one year out after high school and here
they are
and you know 25 years ago it was you
know guys like tim duncan and patrick
ewing were playing four years in college
and
doing what you do in college you know
growing up right
so to have to grow up in the nba at 19
uh and not really knowing anything is
very difficult so we've got to try to do
the best we can
right
um
i want to move on to perhaps um some of
the work you did last year while the
world was in lockdown um you had a
a broadcast called flying coach i
believe with pete carroll
and there was a specific episode um i
believe that was june early june when
you had bret popovich as a cast and this
was right after the george floyd murders
and you described um you know your your
thoughts on that issue you described how
a a flare of yours
i believe andre tadala had to tell you
about the tulsa riots despite you having
been a student of american history in
both high school and college
and i think the words used uh to
describe the moment was an absence of
leadership in our nation there's a
disease
this is very much
a issue with you know specifically the
white population
about a year and a half on steve
what are your thoughts on those topics
today how have you changed how have we
improved if at all
yeah it's so hard because we're being
held back by the incredible division
that exists the political division that
exists
you know what what andre
uh
asked me you know he he said have you
ever did you ever hear the tulsa race
riots i said i said no this was a year
and a half ago since that time
a lot has come out there's there's been
documentaries but
my point at the time was i took you know
several years of american history and
never heard one word about that you know
our our
curriculum in high school and college
when it came to
uh african american history was mainly
you know jackie robinson and and martin
luther king and these figures who we
celebrated
um for good reason
but we didn't flip it around we didn't
we never said okay
why
why was it that jackie robinson wasn't
allowed to play in the big leagues why
weren't black people allowed to play in
the big leagues before that we didn't we
didn't ever really explore that in
school right and
and so now you
you know there's this movement a year
ago and i think everybody
who's
involved
in this movement
the whole point is we need to reconcile
some of our
sins right our original sin especially
we need to to to exam we can't just
ignore it which is what we've done
because you see how it's manifested
itself in so many ways
george floyd's murder being you know an
easy example and a terrible example
um but i think the the point is
what's happened now is so you
immediately get this uh
this this conversation on critical race
theory
which is just nothing more than a fancy
way of saying hey let's teach real
american african-american history to our
kids
and is it seems so simple right it's
like yeah that that would be really good
because then maybe kids could grow up
and learn
um that you know
racism is is really bad and teach them
at a very young age right because it's
clearly something that is sort of yeah
taught
and yet all of a sudden that become you
know the argument is well we don't want
to teach our kids that they're bad and
they're they're bad people like nobody
nobody's suggesting that but this is how
every issue that we have in this country
now becomes it just it's like this and
it's all for political gain and
uh it's it's really demoralizing um and
it's and it's you know just
another example of how we're we're sort
of flailing right now as a country and
and
trying to
you know get our [ __ ] together yeah
unfortunately i mean while the politics
of it play a massive role and would make
all of our lives you know a lot easier
what can we as individuals perhaps
you know do on our on an individual
level in our communities with the people
around us yeah
and you've you shared a little bit about
this earlier but you tell us more about
how you've had perhaps those
uncomfortable
conversations um with your team with
your family and your community
well i think
i think number one we we need to educate
ourselves the best we can whether that's
um
you know through
our own reading or
you know just
extending ourselves and and and
in a way that we haven't done before
i you know brian stevenson is another
incredible guest speaker we had the
civil rights lawyer
and he talks about proximity and and and
he said proximity is so important
and we asked him what do you mean by
proximity well
proximity to the people that you're
trying to help right
boots on the ground you know if you if
you really want to make an impact
um
actually being approximate to um
people you're you're you're trying to
help being
in the community in some form of
grassroots organization
movement
what can you do that actually is going
to
not just make an impact but
you know make you feel it make you feel
what's actually happening
and i think that's what the nba has
really tried to do every
every
team now is connected with a local
grassroots organization that is trying
to
improve
the lives of people in the inner city
and and trying to to to do positive
things in terms of racial relations and
so i think that's
that's the challenge is how do we
actually
feel it and be proximate too you know to
it i love that i've i've not heard that
analogy with proximity before but i
think being present and as close to the
source of it definitely makes a
difference
just stepping back steve
you know the george floyd murder and
racial injustice was just one issue
of many injustices that are happening
around the world and you know some are
captured by the media some are not
how do you as a leader and as a person
with a platform decide when to speed up
on an issue and an injustice versus
whether to not do so and
we too will you know most likely be in
those situations in the business world
where there's a lot happening out there
with our employees our staff our
community
what's the framework we can use how can
we think about what do when do we lean
in when do we when do we not
no it's a great question i think what
i've realized is to to narrow down
my focus to the things that i'm really
uh
passionate about and informed about it's
really difficult to
to go down the path of you know hey i
want to be an activist
and start talking about something you
really don't know a whole lot about
those are those issues are better to to
sit out and so for me
the the issues that i'm
most interested in that have really been
the biggest dynamics in my own life for
gun violence and racial equality
i lost my dad to gun violence when when
i was 18 he was 52
and so gun violence is something that is
is
that affects me deeply and my family
and so i've spent a lot of time
with a lot of the different
gun violence groups gun
violence prevention groups whether it's
sandy hook or the brady foundation or
giffords
march for our lives i've i've done
fundraising but i've also learned a lot
and so i feel much more comfortable
speaking out about those things um
and then the racial justice it's just
you know i'm
i'm
living every day with a group of people
whose lives are directly impacted and
whose families are directly impacted by
the injustice that exists and so
it's really easy for me to to feel
um passionate and and connected to those
things yeah it sounds it's always going
to be a personal choice but using
the idea of being informed and educated
on those topics is a good starting way
of deciding when to
when to lean into those issues
yeah i mean and that's uh i think that's
sort of personal choice too i mean i
i've been pretty um
passionate about those issues for a long
time but i just leaned into them
maybe five six years ago i think
i've told the story before but we
i think it might have been the 2016
finals um
maybe it was the conference finals but
we had
our third
moment of silence in as many weeks
this was the pulse nightclub uh massive
orlando yeah in orlando
and we were you know we were having this
huge game and we haven't yet another
moment of silence and uh
it's like
so we what are we just gonna keep keep
doing this we're just you know like it's
great let's honor
the the victims and their families but
maybe we should
you know excuse my language maybe we
should effing do something about it
right yeah and it's just it's
infuriating it's inferior and i finally
just had enough and i decided just sort
of
apropos of nothing i was doing a podcast
local podcast with tim kawakami um
and he and about basketball and i just i
brought it up and
took a lot of a lot of heat for it um
from you know gun rights activists and
and learned a lot and uh but it was good
it was it felt good and it
sort of
got my you know i dove in and and i
started to get my bearings and
started to realize where i could
actually make an impact yeah
thanks for sharing that i did not know
about that 2016 finals and the podcast
so
that was inspiring
before we open it up to q a wanted to
ask a question which we plan to ask all
of our speakers this year for be from
the top
our theme steve is beyond expectations
um
you've certainly in the stories you've
shared right now
you know gone beyond the expectations
set forth by you by society for a
nba player a gm a head coach
if youtube just summarize what inspires
you what motivates you to go beyond just
those expectations what would you say
i think what i love about
coaching and what
inspires me is this feeling of
generating
joy and happiness as a group
um it's it just it gives me chills just
thinking about a team
that's connected and playing well
and laughing i'm really excited about
this year we had our first exhibition
game last night
and
you know this tara but you know
sometimes you just feel it and sometimes
you don't like and
like
last night i'm watching our game and
i just had chills like this group is
connected
going to have a really fun season
and that's what
keeps me coming to work every day and
and wanting to
to really succeed is
that feeling of momentum when something
when you when you you just grasp
something then you can feel it and it
starts to grow and you're just trying to
feed it
and so many people
are
interested in it
and and enjoying it as well and so when
our team plays well and the community
gets involved and all of a sudden
everybody's excited
um
that's the best feeling there is for me
that's great and as a warriors fan
you're getting chills on the first
preseason james that is exciting it
bodes well for the rest of our season
and
i'm excited for that great let's open it
up to questions um i think we have the
first one
right over there you could just
introduce yourself please
hey steven first of all thank you very
much for being with us tonight
i'm santiago patarka class of 2023
unlike manu ginobili i'm from argentina
um i wanted to travel back in time to
1997
game six against the yuda jazz of carl
madon and john stockton
you call a timeout 25 seconds left on
the clock
what were you thinking how did you
manage
how did you manage
to convince just
michael jordan
uh when you went into the huddle you
look him in the ice and shouted if you
need it if he comes up i will be ready
you must
well you just told the story so that was
uh yeah
that was the that was the moment that
every kid dreams of you know when you're
shooting in your driveway or you know at
school or whatever and you count down
the seconds and nba championship
on the line and and um
so to to actually live that was um
incredible um
when you're a kid when you miss you just
pretend that you got fouled and now you
go to the free throw line and you shoot
two free throws
and uh but when it's happening you know
you don't you can't quite
have that luxury um
but it was a it was
a moment that i think
it took me a long time to get to the
point where i
could uh actually succeed in a situation
like that i was very self-conscious when
i started playing
um in the nba and i didn't really
feel
clutch you know i felt like i was
thinking too much and
so i learned a lot especially from
michael jordan who took game winning
shots almost every you know week
and missed plenty of them and um
didn't seem to bother him that much you
know and
there was a great lesson in there that
you got to go for it
and you got to be able to live with
the failure if you don't but but the the
best way to succeed is
without considering the failure without
you know just just playing just going
and and you know getting getting out of
your own head
and so that was a moment for me that was
probably years in the making
and uh so obviously a great great moment
and something i'll i'll have forever
next question
we have one bathtub
steve thanks so much for speaking with
us today my name is tejas i'm a first
year mba student here
and my question today is about building
championship culture
this is tough for me to say is a
lifelong cleveland cavaliers fan but if
you could take us back to 2015
uh what were your top uh priorities and
values that you sought to instill in the
organization and who did you work with
and lean on to help build these values
and priorities yeah
thank you for the question
and uh congratulations on the 2016
championship
so when i when i became a coach i
i spent a lot of time preparing to coach
um
but i didn't become a coach until i was
49 so
i had
i did some television work after i was
done playing and i spent a lot of time
preparing and i talked to a lot of
coaches and one of the guys who
really made an impact on me was pete
carroll and i went to see pete in
seattle i loved the way his teams played
and i and i
sat down with him and
pete just
said after we had spent a couple of days
together and i was watching you know
watching practice and
he we sat down in his office and he said
so how are you going to coach your team
i said you mean like what offense are we
going to run he said no that stuff
doesn't even matter like you know and i
i just spent like a year trying to
figure out what our offense was going to
look like you know
he said really you know that stuff
you'll figure out he said it's the you
know what what's it going to feel like
for the coaches for the players and the
coaches to come into the gym every day
and
what's your culture going to be like and
and
i suppose i had never really thought of
it in those terms but i
you know i knew playing for phil and pop
they had built these amazing cultures
but pete really sort of
clarified you know and he told me the
story of how he
sort of figured out how to
incorporate a culture and he he asked me
to to to go home and think of the four
values that that were the most important
values in my life
and that my job as a coach
was once i figured out what those values
were
was to make those values come alive
every day and that the players would
feel that authenticity since they are my
values
and and so
that was pete was the guy who sort of
like laid it out there and it was really
fascinating
joy and competition were two of them
mindfulness uh
was another one um we everything that we
did
um
was built on on competing
and joy
and and mindfulness and compassion was
the fourth one um
so everything we did and the way we
treated the team was based on those
values we we incorporated a ton of joy
into our practice sessions we competed
at everything we kept score of
everything we treated our players with
great compassion
but making those values come alive um to
me was
the the lesson of this is this is what
it means to to build a culture
we have time for one last one over there
we'll wrap up yeah
hi
um this is diego ramirez uh
nba 23 from mexico so my question is
regarding how you experience different
joys as a player and as a coach
i practice support competitively and one
of my greatest fears has been retirement
because i feel that it is a great part
of my identity that i'm gonna lose
what has been your favorite part of
coaching and how do you compare the
feeling of winning a championship as a
player and as a coach yeah
great question i think as a as a player
you're very
uh
locked in on your own
uh your own game your own routine and as
a coach you're thinking about everybody
else and and
you're trying to help everyone so
actually i found winning
the championship as a coach was even
more gratifying than than as a player
because you
because you've put in all this energy
into the whole group and you see
everyone how happy everyone in the
organization is
and when you're a player it's an amazing
feeling too especially with your
teammates
but it's more it's it's more insular
it's more
you know you're you're just locked in on
your own routine day after day and
like coaching is you know you feel
responsible for everyone
that's great
um thanks for answering those steve we
are we're almost done um before we let
you draw we want to do a quick lightning
round okay um i'll mention a couple of
words or phrases and just
you pit one of them
ready yup okay
um space jam one or space jam two
one
one okay so does that mean jordan over
lebron or is that not
just an indictment on their acting not
their not their players just as actors
yeah
i didn't see space jam too so okay so
there we go um messi or ronaldo
oh uh messi
there's my there's my argentinian guy
right there
what's your team what's your what's
liverpool they're a pool
you have some liverpool in here as well
um
roger federer rafael nadal nobel novak
djotrovic
uh
roger federer roger federer okay
proud caesar
better dressed team
1996 bulls or 2017 warriors
uh
do coaches count
you were a player on one not a touch in
the other 27 2017 warriors because i was
a player on 96 bulls and i brought the
level you brought them down
that's fair
best city for food in the nba ooh
chicago chicago
great
and last one
losing game seven of the nba finals to
lebron james
at home
on father's day
or
getting punched in the face by michael
jordan
wow
that's uh that's quite a way to finish
tonight
really uplifting
[Laughter]
anyway i uh
i don't know if you know this but i
um actually went at yup michael and i
i i actually hit him in the fist with my
jaw
we have an answer that's an answer
[Applause]
i think that was a winner
but that was a lot of fun i get an
ovation for getting punched that's a
really i'm not trying i'm not i'm not
sure i understand but
go with it
um thanks for your time i think we
learned a lot uh we really appreciate
this steve i think you've left us
with lessons on mindfulness on
authenticity
on proximity that i think we all can
take with us as we graduate and move on
from the gsb i want to wish you your
family the team um good best of health
and good luck for the season and draw
warriors all right thank you thank you
appreciate
it we're done yeah
thank you
thank you
[Music]